Hi, and welcome to this very natural setting.
Today, I want to talk about a revolutionary approach...
...on how to connect our world without being super weird.
Some said it's not possible.
Some said it's out of reach.
To them, we say it's already here.
Seriously, look, it's right here.
And what do we call this not so new chapter in human connectivity?
The Icelandverse,...
...enhanced actual reality without silly-looking headsets.
In our open world experience, everything is real...
...and has been for millions of years.
It's completely immersive with water that's wet,...
...with humans to connect with.
You're human, right?
Isn't she funny?
In the Icelandverse, there's real moss you can look at,...
Please don't touch it.
It's very delicate.
...skies you can see with your eyeballs,...
...volcanic rocks you can caress,...
...really big geysers you can observe from a safe distance;...
...birds you can watch,...
They're really cute, but a bit stupid.
...waterfalls you can stand near, like this one, that one,...
...this one, that one...
...and even this one;...
...horses you can ride...
...with hair you can touch.
The Icelandverse is a world with possibilities so endless,...
...they'll be here forever.
So join us today or tomorrow or whenever.
We are really easygoing.
Now, please enjoy our logo.